ame
にゃんぐさんから推奨人が出ましたこれはもうねぇ
あっあってますね失敗かなと思ってないんですけど
back こちらゲイキーター
贈答東欧思いがまっずい前半30キロカロリー
いいいい
バッカー
ぱっくりややばいと思いますよそもそもギガ max が出た時点で2000何
キロカロリーの部屋が馬鹿とかよりなんですけどもう人が以前珍食とるカロリー分なん
ですよに選手を言ってその場みたいなカロリーに激辛ペヤング集またもバックから遺伝
子を合体させたらもう食えるわけないだろう
君ですけどくんですねこれはホントちょっとねぇ
ua グーッド入れてちょっとわかんないですけど吹き飛びていきましょうか
激辛ペアンが長調オーボンティガー負けた2000136kcal 1日食までにして
くださいっ
なんかも渓谷みたいになってますねカロリー摂取水準を上回る可能性がありますと
カーナビが強いので小さいお子さんやたライトが苦手な方は
きっ
キッズ所キッズ食って何きつ食って2箱吸うみたいなてますねきつ色
もうなんか pay and end 路線で感覚が麻痺してるのかわからないんです
けどこの赤い激辛ピアノおっ
そかないんですよ方で食えるんかなそれ自身がないですけどできるフェーリがんばって
みようと思いますなぜ私は講師ですから上げていきましょう
スタートの意味で一日おりますですにーっねえねえ
[音楽]
ブーバしか開けですからこれまで一気取り入れ食ったラッパ型 are you
here 一発にょ
ではさん
になっちゃいますよ
ああああああ
まあやはり火曜日のする綾部分
あっ
[音楽]
ガーッとやり妻の量じゃねーよゆっくり終わりました
ええええっ
[音楽]
あー間で最近フェアウェイエンドっていうもっとからやってばっかり食べてて
this 比べアームの辛さを調和されかけてなんですけどめっちゃつかないんです
けどなら食べれる美味しいカーサだった覚えがありますよって言われるとまだ
なぜ派
[音楽]
1相関をてオネストユーミンが始まる前からちょっと汗かいてるんだ
さあ授業できましたギターピアノギガ max 2009カロリーと辛さの暴力話して
私の舌が先にやられるのか
胃袋が先にやられるのか jean louis とペヤングの新たな一戦の開幕です
ちなみにご覧ください2述べアクトが大き寒さはこれくらいになっておりますカロリー
オフ2
のペン部の約4倍暑さもまるで違いますただないテーマ
バッハ
ということで温度的にも問題はないでしょ
食べてみようと思いますまあなぜ何事も挑戦ですから
いただけます最初でだいたいどれくらいがカーサかっていうのを知りたいですね
何
[音楽]
終わったこれを何回食べればいいんだろうか美味しいですかないけどおいしいのでまだ
なんかいけそうですね
さああああ
あーはーいけどおいしい
全然うまいねフェアウェイのせいで慣れてるんだかもしれない全然そんな殺人的な辛さ
全然3人的なさあそうじゃないでした
[音楽]
やべえっいや終わったらいや別にフォスターなんだこれはあれですねギリギリセーフ
ですどうしようもないよ
プラウじゃないんですよ
[音楽]
に食べる感想ですんですよ
うわぁソナー
ああああああ
ああ皆さんお気づきで所北ここまでの妙望んでないんですよ
これ作戦で量が多いので水の音阿部れるようちょっと増やしちゃうと食べ食べれないと
思うんですよね
なんであの水は飲めません
[音楽]
半分以下つしてこれですね
葉っぱちょっとはばせ量がすごいやってもおいしいおいしいてできる
ええええええ
などまとまったらダメなんすよこれを待ったらもうからいって思っちゃうんで甘いで
空想
ずっ
ua
[音楽]
や晴れまじでやばいやばいやばい量が多い量が多い票が多いよこれ
出雲なが終わってるので
[音楽]
なんだ水飲みすぎるとマジでくれだけなるなんと2000キロカロリーが伝えています
からそれも半分際波聞くってると思います
おっ
はい
ねええええ
re
[音楽]
ん
あの殻付最高級にきついです膿疱が体協で辛さももうすぐない声量も普通に人が1日
取るカロリーもあるしねこれでも細部ののこと自体も多分ダメなんですよね食べる
スペースがなくなってくるんでえっ
強敵でこれからもう結構マリア全然ある8報復演歌をすれ
やばいお腹がいっぱいね
5ですこれ端末がんでしょ多分水を飲みすぎたせいでもうた分得になってるんですけど
も飲まないとから来てくれないんで結構
追い詰められてますねこれ
あと半分ぐらいの3つのこっから打っていくいまー
[音楽]
マジでつけどな俺は
ユーチューバーなできるできないじゃない
言われたやるじゃない
[音楽]
yeah
me
yeah yeah
dea
car
wh
これはすごい痩せてね渦へ食べる言われますダメな時にあの
行くだありません見てもらった通りからさ
執事はうすべてにおいて人間の限界値だと思いますこれ多分余裕で食える人はもうた
からいいのが得意かつ大食いの2つに当てはまらないと食えないタイプですね
なぁや食べてみてこれ一人で食えたら本当にすごいと思います
[音楽]
よく頑張ったはずね